bonsoir je vous présente le soleil le
soleil sur terre le jour il nous sert à
nous éclairer et la nuit deux
alternatives pour s'éclairer le feu et
l'électricité
le soleil fait également son travail la
nuit pour nous éclairer la juge toujours
pardon mais la nuit qu'en est il pour se
repérer sous les océans le feu un petit
peu compliqué sous louer puis
l'électricité on a décidé de pas essayer
et puis finalement la réponse
ça s'appelle la bioluminescence c'est la
capacité qu'ont 90% des animaux marins à
produire de la lumière naturelle grâce à
une réaction chimique 7,2 me sens et
donc régie par un gène chez ces
organismes plancton calamars crevettes
méduses mais elle se trouve aussi sur
terre d'ailleurs chez des lucioles chez
des vers luisants 7,2 lui naissance est
connue scientifiquement depuis les
années soixante dix et sert aujourd'hui
à mener des recherches et faire du
marquage génétique mais en fait cette de
luminescence elle est le centre
d'intérêt et de curiosité depuis bien
plus longtemps que cela déjà dans
l'antiquité le romain pline l'ancien
disait que les méduses brille tant qu'on
pourrait en faire des torches et puis
plus tard les indiens d'amérique
enfermer des coureuses qui sont des
petits insectes bio l'humiliation qui
vivent dans forêt amazonienne dans des
cages pour éclairer leurs maisons il
s'en servait aussi pour leur chasse de
nuit
accrochés à leurs pieds pour faire fuir
les serpents et puis pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale les traînées
bioluminescente laissés par les
porte-avions servait de point de repère
aux avions de chasse 7,2 minescence elle
existe sous plateforme dans la nature
elle est souvent en régie par une
fonction biologique chasse et se
reproduire se camoufler et 7 de
luminescence elle existe également à
l'échelle des bactéries et ce sont ces
bactéries qui vivent en symbiose chez
des êtres comme les calamars le calamar
héberge en lui un organe rempli de
bactéries bleu lumineux
entre qui lui permet de produire de la
lumière pour camoufler l'ombre qui se
projette sur le sol de la mer pour se
cacher ces prédateurs et ce sont ces
bactéries qui nous intéresse pour
produire une solution d'éclairage
biologique
alors vous allez nous dire débarquer des
bactéries c'est dégoûtant
c'est forcément moche et méchant eh bien
non figurez vous que vous allez sur vous
10 millions de fois plus de bactéries
que de cellules humaines et ces
bactéries self bien souvent votre
bien-être pour pourrions de la lumière à
partir de bactéries
il faut les exploiter forcément alors
l'exploitation c'est très cruel et bien
figurez vous là je suis plein de
bactéries et puis vous quand vous vous
lavez les mains que vous faites le
ménage fait un vrai massacre de
bactéries ce que je veux vous dire c'est
que les bactéries ne sont pas des
animaux
ce sont des micro organismes qui n'ont
pas de conscience une fois qu'on a ça en
tête on peut s'en servir pour faire
plein de choses
en l'occurrence de la lumière et nous on
utilise des bactéries qui sont des
bactéries très communément utilisées en
laboratoire les bactéries qui ne sont
pas pathogènes qui ne sont pas toxiques
non plus et qui viennent directement de
votre estomac en laboratoire nous
donnons la faculté à ces bactéries la
faculté de produire de la lumière via
cette réaction chimique de production de
photons et pour cela il faut bactéries
plusieurs choses des nutriments des
conditions de température des conditions
de milieu
tout ça dans le but de faire un système
d'éclairage autonome
donc pour nous produire notre système
d'éclairage nous mettons des bactéries
des nutriments
le tout formant une solution gélifiée à
l'intérieur d'une coque transparente qui
va pouvoir être adhésives a beaucoup de
surfaces lisses et ainsi éclairer de
manière autonome
du coup pas d'électricité et si nous
pouvons réfléchir à un système pour
produire de la lumière sans électricité
qu'est ce que cela changerait vraiment
dans notre manière de faire et bien déjà
ça changerait le paradigme même de
l'objet lumière blanc poule puisque la
lumière ne serait plus un objet mais
bien une matière une matière première
une matière première vie
entre qui se reproduit une matière
première qui a des besoins nouveaux
différents du sucre de l'oxygène mais
aussi une matière première portable
puisqu'elle fonctionne en autosuffisance
l'énergie de la bulle message vient de
l'intérieur même de micro-organismes et
ne dépend pas comme un panneau solaire
par exemple d'une charge extérieur c'est
également un système qui est
complètement indépendant d'une
infrastructure électrique
et bien en fait ça ça change juste tout
ça change que c'est une lumière plus
juste une lumière qui pourrait servir à
la fois aux 1,2 milliard de personnes
qui vivent dans le noir privés
d'électricité mais aussi une lumière qui
pourrait réduire les 15 % d'électricité
dans le monde qui sont utilisés pour la
lumière et qui sont responsables de 5 %
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
une lumière donc plus juste puisqu'elle
peut répondre à des problématiques à la
fois écologique et humaine
alors c'est pas pour ça qu'on voit tout
noir ou tout blanc
l'idée ce n'est pas de dire que la bo de
naissance d'une solution radicale pour
éradiquer l'électricité dans le monde
mais plutôt de se dire que si on veut
avoir un impact l'objectif c'est de
diversifier les énergies de mettre la
meilleure source d'énergie au meilleur
endroit est donc cette de luminescence
elle peut être utilisée par exemple là
où l'électricité est interdite
aujourd'hui sur les vitrines des
magasins
elle peut également être utilisée dans
le paysage urbain pour éclairer pour
signaler pour mettre en valeur sur des
façades sort de la signalétique sur du
mobilier urbain
elle peut également être utilisée dans
des zones où l'électricité est trop
compliqué ou trop coûteuses à apporter
comme dans des parkings sur des
chantiers mais aussi dans des zones en
pays émergents ou encore dans des parcs
des rêveurs desjardins aujourd'hui cette
technologie existe nous sommes en train
de la développer
après un an de laboratoires nous avons
atteint 72 heures de lumière en continu
et avons pour objectif l'année prochaine
d'atteindre un mois dur et de lumière
pour se développer dans de nouveaux
horizons mais en fait en faisant
progresser cette technologie nous
pouvons penser plus en plus loin déjà on
pourrait cultiver notre lumière cultiver
la lumière sur le bord des routes
cultiver la lumière dans des villes
pour lire le soir cultiver la lumière et
la rendre en libre service pour éclairer
de plus grands espaces
mais pourquoi pas aussi penser une
lumière en poudre une sorte de lumière
instantanée lumière qui pourrait servir
au cours de voyages qui pourrait servir
lors de graves coupures d'électricité
pourquoi pas aussi imaginer une lumière
qui se recharge qui se nourrit est ce
que le facteur de demain est un espèce
de d'allumeurs de réverbères 2.0 ne
pourraient pas venir alimenter ses
sources de lumière et enfin le graal une
matière première de luminescentes qui
pourrait être appliquée à toute surface
pour les rendre lumineuse alors selon
moi si on ne veut pas se dire qu'on a
loupé quelque chose dans 200 ans
quand on sera envahie par les océans à
cause de nos propres excès et qu'on sera
finalement éclairé par ces poissons de
luminescents en disant que c'était
peut-être la solution qui aurait pu
faire basculer notre destin bien je vous
redis d'embarquer avec nous dans l'
aventure de la révolution des
illuminations
merci